[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france 24 por
16 años angela merkel llevo en sus
hombros las riendas de su país como
canciller alemana y con ese puesto
asumió también la responsabilidad tácita
de liderar el proyecto europeo y lo hizo
con maestría pero en 2018 anunció que ya
no buscaría otra reelección y llegado el
día a su nombre no fue incluido en las
papeletas hoy la conversaciones es sobre
su legado como la mujer más poderosa del
mundo respetada y seguida pese a ser un
lunar en las salas de discusión mundial
dominadas por la presencia de hombres
gobernantes es angela merkel un símbolo
feminista veamos
un icono feminista se va del poder
tras 16 años de protagonismo en la
política internacional angela merkel
cumple su promesa de dar el paso al
costado pero dejando claras lecciones de
poderío y experiencia entre afines y
opositores
pese a gozar de una voz fuerte en la
política global hasta hace poco no se
atrevía a llamarse feminista
la historia del feminismo es una en la
que hay cosas que se aplican a mí y
luego hay cosas que no han sido y no
quiero decorar me con un título que en
realidad no tengo
pero su mera presencia ya era un acto de
rebeldía contra el patriarcado desde su
primer mandato en 2005
alemania no estaba realmente preparada
para una canciller y cuando fue elegida
con una mayoría de medio millón de votos
el ex canciller schröder salió a la
televisión y dijo no está a la altura de
esto seguiré adelante aunque cuatro años
antes sólo había tenido una mayoría de
60.000 votos en las esferas políticas
alemania se preguntaba si esa mujer era
capaz de liderar por el mensaje que
perduró fue muy distinto
después de que fue elegida hice un
comentario en la televisión en el que
dije que finalmente las niñas en la
alemania podían soñar no solo con
convertirse en peluquera sino tal vez en
canciller y para nosotras las mujeres de
todo el mundo y ella es admirada por
mujeres de todo el mundo este es su
principal legado
solitaria la conservadora democracia
cristiana dominada por hombres apoyó a
regañadientes políticas feministas como
las cuotas para mujeres en las juntas
directivas o el aumento del cuidado
infantil financiado por el estado pero
con los años ya en el ocaso de su
mandato finalmente esta física cuántica
que se vinculó a la política con la
caída del muro de berlín ha llegado a
abrazar la realidad de su posición
así que hoy puedo responder la pregunta
con un sí y decir que soy feminista
antes en el escenario trate de expresar
el punto con algo más de timidez hoy he
pensado más en mi respuesta y puedo
decir que si todos deberíamos ser
feministas
[Aplausos]
sus declaraciones en un evento con la
escritora nigeriana chimamanda
negociadas y fueron definitivas y su
impacto ha sido profundo en un mundo que
cambia lentamente los roles
tradicionales de género
hay una broma en alemania un niño
pequeño pregunta mamá los hombres
también pueden ser canciller
nos acompañan desde berlín alemania
cristina mendoza webber periodista
colombo alemana y como autora del
reportaje de largo aliento el libro
angela merkel la física del poder
christina bienvenida a ella soy
muchas gracias por la invitación y un
placer estar aquí en france 24
era merkel feminista su existencia en el
mundo si lo es pero ella impulsó
iniciativas realmente feministas
realmente con fuerza que hicieron mella
en el mundo
yo creo que la cuestión aquí también es
como lo vemos en el reportaje de que
acaban de mostrar es que angela merkel
siempre fue muy reacia hasta el 8 de
septiembre de 2021 de considerarse o
definirse como una mujer feminista y en
este caso yo creo que hay que aclarar
también que angela merkel no lo hizo
antes porque a ella no le gusta que la
encasillen en diferentes ideologías ella
solamente pertenecía ahora bueno también
adam se ha definido como feminista pero
pertenecía solamente a la cdu su partido
a la iglesia protestante su religión y a
una pequeña capilla que se construyó en
su padre el pastor luterano por su
carácter en templin en su patria chica
angela merkel es definida por todo el
mundo podemos decir como feminista pero
ella misma no se consideraba feminista
porque no le gustaba a adornarse con
etiquetas que no habían luchado ella
misma lo dijo también en la última
entrevista ella en el reportaje vemos
por ejemplo al es falsa a dis falsa es
la es la es la insignia del movimiento
feminista aquí en alemania
y ellas se conocieron en 1993 cuando
angela merkel tuvo un ligero
contratiempo digamos con una feminista
en un top show en el programa de debate
donde donde esta feminista iracunda
actuó de manera muy radical y extremista
angela merkel se ha definido digamos el
feminismo de una manera diferente
digamos a los radicalismos y es que para
ella lo importante es la paridad entre
hombres y mujeres y si logro algunas
cosas y las logro desde mucho antes de
convertirse en canciller de alemania
estamos hablando de 1994 cuando era
ministra para asuntos de la mujer y de
la juventud y logró incluir en la
constitución alemana en el artículo 3 de
la constitución sobre igualdad un
parágrafo donde es el estado el que
garantizará esta paridad de igualdad
entre hombres y mujeres
christina usted que se ha dedicado tanto
a estudiar la vida y sobre todo la obra
de ángela merkel háblenos de su persona
un personaje icónico en su forma de
vestir en las posiciones de sus manos
una imagen para la memoria que nos queda
que ha sido una de las mujeres más
poderosas de la historia la mano que por
nada más y nada menos que 16 años llevó
los rumbos de alemania y mantuvo firme
el timón también de la unión europea
bueno en cuanto a su propia experiencia
física yo creo que lo importante que hay
que decir acá es que angela merkel
definió desde hace mucho tiempo que el
ser mujer también era gran yo no diría
una desventaja pero si proveían mayores
retos en un mundo dominado por hombres
la política en realidad cuando ya
incursionó cuando ella se convirtió en
canciller de alemania y por el cual
también en 2006 fue nombrada por primera
vez la mujer más poderosa del mundo fue
porque ella incursionó en un mundo de
hombres en un mundo dominado por hombres
angela merkel cuando fue cuando empezó
la campaña electoral tuvo que mejorar su
apariencia física pública pero también
lo que hizo fue conservar una llanes a
unos rasgos minimalistas porque ella
siempre dijo que al ser mujer
las mujeres en
espacios públicos tenían contaban con
una serie de desventajas que tenían que
ver con cómo estaban peinadas y tenían
aretes como estaban maquilladas sí sí sí
tenía el color de las uñas pintadas como
estaban vestidas entonces por eso vemos
a una mujer que claro le pintan el color
del cabello
pero poco si nos damos cuenta ella no
utiliza otro solamente dos accesorios la
cadenita que estamos viendo en este
momento que tiene alrededor de 15 que va
a intercambiando y un reloj enfoque a
titanium que es con el que siempre ha
estado lleva una cartera bastante normal
grande para llevar todos sus documentos
pero más allá de eso en realidad ella lo
que quiere es que la gente se enfoque en
su discurso en lo que dice más allá de
cómo está peinada o cómo está maquillada
o cómo está vestida y eso para ella es
fundamental también porque de alguna
manera también se acerca a los alemanes
no no para ella lo importante su
discurso sus políticas y sus opiniones
sobre diferentes puntos de vista una
pregunta que siempre es urgente los
curiosos porque angela merkel nunca
cambió su apellido
angela merkel no cambia a ver a angela
merkel se casó en primeras en primeras
nupcias este caso con un remake el un
estudiante también de física ellos se
casaron en 1977
y ella conservó su apellido lo cual
también llevó a que a que su marido
fuera reconocido también
internacionalmente después de que se
separaran en 1981 no lo cambió después
cuando se casó por segunda vez con con
joachim sauer su actual marido porque
estaba también en yo creo que tiene que
ver también con que
se casó con la iglesia en la primera vez
la segunda ya no se podía casar por la
iglesia pero al mismo tiempo no se
cambió el apellido porque ya la conocían
como angela merkel y adquirir también el
apellido de su marido en sour significa
en alemán también amargo entonces creo
que si hubieran hecho la traducción
tampoco hubiera quedado bastante bien se
le conoce como angela merkel para ella
pues simplemente lo que quedó de ella y
es un rasgo distintivo nadie casi nadie
conoce que su primer apellido es carnal
el del sur el de su o el de su padre
pero en realidad no lo cambió porque
porque ya seguía parte como de su de su
marca lo bueno y ya para el cierre
cristina rápidamente quisiera
preguntarle para usted cuál es el legado
para las mujeres específicamente que
deja angela merkel en política y
solamente con su figura
pero yo creo que angela merkel cumplió
varios hitos a nivel internacional no
solamente en alemán y sino también
internacional comenzamos con que fue la
parlamentaria más joven de la extinta
república democrática alemana en acceder
al parlamento reunificado en 1991
después fue la primera mujer en la
historia de la república federal de
alemania y también del partido en
realidad de la cdu en convertirse en
mujer presidenta del partido y fue la
primera canciller en
alemania pero aparte de eso ha sido
nombrada 14 veces de las 16 ediciones de
la revista forbes como la mujer más
poderosa del mundo ha cumplido
diferentes hitos como también mantener a
la unión europea cohesionada aunque
tienen muchos problemas internos pero
pero para ella el proceso de integración
ha sido una de sus banderas a nivel de
política exterior y sobre todo también
ha sido antítesis de los populismos y de
los nacionalismos como presidentes como
ya el expresidente trump y ahora pues el
presidente bolsonaro sin duda también es
simplemente la posición de ver que las
mujeres pueden acceder a cargos tan
altos y obviamente va a dejar la vara
muy alta para las personas que lleguen
quiero finalizar con una frase que ya
dijo en 2019 cuando le preguntaron en su
distrito electoral tras un rival como
quería que en 50 años los niños leyeran
sobre ella en los libros de historia y
ella dijo simplemente tres palabras ella
lo intentó
christina un placer gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y a nuestros
televidentes desee que continúen en
france24 y también nos vemos
próximamente en ella sois
[Música]